[Music]
will you take part in
my life
my love
that is
[Music]
hold on getting a puppy is adorable but
it's also a real challenge the last
thing i want you to do is get a puppy
and end up regretting it so here are
five things you must know before you get
a puppy
puppy depression is very common and i'm
not talking about the puppy being
depressed i'm talking about you no not
me you you have all these expectations
that you and your puppy are going to be
cuddling on the couch and next thing you
know the puppy just wants to be alone in
the kitchen this is very normal don't
have those feelings of buyer's remorse
give it time allow the puppy to
acclimate training takes patience
feeding a young puppy is really tricky
you have to feed them up to four times a
day especially ones as big as bitter
okay
a lot of people think they can just free
feed their puppies leave a bowl of food
and the puppy will figure it out no your
puppy will become obese and then guess
what every time your puppy eats it needs
to poop so your house is going to be
covered in poop and have you ever seen a
new feast poop
that is one big pilot
walking a puppy is no easy feat but is
extremely important doesn't matter if
it's raining if it's snowing you still
have to walk your puppy and most people
get their puppies around 10 weeks of age
which means that a walk is necessary
every three to four hours so if you're
working an eight hour work day maybe a
puppy isn't for you when walking your
new puppy you may come off rude to other
dog owners because you can't just let
your puppy play on leash with other pups
it's gonna turn into trouble leashes are
gonna get tangled someone's gonna get
bitten not a great idea plus it's no
good if you want a well-behaved pup
come on pop good boy dogs get dirty i
mean bear when he sees mud he not only
walks in it he lies down in it he rolls
around in it he drools in itself but
thankfully he likes taking baths so it's
not such a painful process but some dogs
hate bats so it's really going to be
personality dependent you really
shouldn't use human products on your dog
no to human shampoo and no to human hair
dryers
special dog dryer it's not too hot and
it essentially blows the water off the
duck
and it's not just bathing him you gotta
brush him you gotta clip his toenails
this is a true time commitment
crate training is by far the most
effective way to house break your dog
and to make sure they don't destroy your
home what the [ __ ] did you do go inside
go
dogs are den creatures they loved
enclosed spaces bear goes in here after
playing with roxy and it's his place to
rest he sleeps here he hangs out here
and he's not going to pee in here
because it's such an enclosed space
proving how much he loves his crate even
when i open the door he doesn't feel the
need to run out because this is his home
he loves it in there
[Applause]
i did thorough research before i got
there and i was warned about drool and
big breeds but holy moly how much drool
there is
there's drool in my food i take drool
with me to work on my clothes it's on my
mirrors the drool struggle is real
the cost struggle is real too outside of
paying for basic pet supplies you also
have to plan for vet visits vaccinations
and if your pet gets sick the bills
really rack up in fact bear sick right
now and needs antibiotics this is
expensive on any budget look i don't
want it to seem like i'm against you
getting a puppy i love puppies i've made
other videos with these guys before and
they're truly part of my family but i
want you to be prepared for the
challenges that lay ahead so if you know
someone that's about to get a puppy or
thinking about getting a puppy
definitely share this video with them if
you enjoyed it give it a like as always
stay happy and healthy
keep going keep coming keep coming come
on more
perhaps you could have stayed what's fun
the cost struggle is real too
is real i'm against some
i don't know what that was
oh use a dog
what is this thing called